[Music]
this forest has gone master this time
he's okay meatlug the got a son at a
[ __ ] boat big time I can't even imagine
looking down at the hoop like that
orange or donk
yes a pass
right-handed hair he came in Belize
remember the top rated defensive team in
the league
- on a flush he gets through their
defense transition is nothing broad and
kind of probing yeah there's a nice
diamonds mold by the crossover Club we
didn't even have a chance to get his
hands up in the air that's three
straight for Lopez and here comes
Showtime pathetic
Yanis punctuating an 11 to Milwaukee Ron
and hopefully he get the jump shot and
this is going against virtually a
7-footer as well and Kevin Durant what
if he just decides to only dunk my
goodness he could still be just fine
that's your next paycheck why do people
talk about
she does some other things pretty rough
you'd like that even team at jump
dresses and the Bucks are at shooting
too cuz they're not used to it
yes
[Applause]
Littleton steel
[Applause]
watch how high he gets up one-handed
side level to the rim wash it down big
fella
[Applause]
flips it up off the rail off the
backboard
I pick and roll Yannick on the loose
are you kidding
I've heard of a hook shot that was a
hook dump sweeps that thing on through
that might be the play of the
here so far